Họng 20 bà dường ngày 20 tháng 20 năm, tại cú lộ một đoạn qua sát cầm suyên, tình hà tính,
sế ra vụ tên an giá thông đến hoàn dữ bà xe uto, khiến 20 tuy vào.
Và thời điểm trên, xe uto tại mang bình kiểm soát năm 20 xa 5 năm bài,
rất tài xe dương kịch tâm, sinh 1 miền chính xam chỉ biết chính, chú xa xuân tài xân.
Thế phố chỉ mình, được khiến theo đúng nằm bắt, đã và trạm cùng chú với uto còn mang bình kiểm soát bà mi tà mà.
Sống một xa uta không, gió ông nở tế bê, sinh 1 miền chính xam tâm,
gió xa thì cầm, hà tính, được khiến, chở thông vào ở bà hài con.
Sau và trạm, xe con bị đầy sang là được vụ chiều, và tích tục và trạm với xe uto
hách mang bình kiểm soát bà miền bài hát không bài xa uta năm soát tại xíy huyên
học chính, sinh 1 miền chính xam tâm xa ủ, chú tài phường thình, tình nghe an, được khiến.
Họ qua, ông bê từ vong tại chỗ, vợ vào hài con của ông bê bị thương nả.
Đến dạo sang hủ sau, chó ủ, sinh 1 miền xa ủ, con gái của ông bê khu khu khòa.
Hịt, vô thêm ạng đăng được kêu quan trích năng được chá, làm so.